This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. At some point in our lives, many of us realized that the way we hear our own voice, isn't the way others hear our voice. Shay had that realization as a child, helping out at the family business, a Delhi, in southwest Virginia. We did a lot of business with the Delhi, a lot of call-in orders, and I had to answer the phone with the name of the business often when the phone rang the same thing happened over and over again vividly remember always being confused for my mother. They would always say oh hey Judy
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们人生的某个时刻，我们许多人意识到，我们自己听到的声音，和别人听到的我们的声音并不一样。谢伊在小时候就意识到了这一点，当时她在弗吉尼亚州西南部一家名为德里的家族企业帮忙。“我们和德里有很多业务往来，有很多电话订单，我经常得用店名接电话，通常当电话铃响时，同样的事情会一次又一次地发生，我清晰地记得我总是被误认为是我母亲。他们总是说，哦，嘿，朱迪。”
You know and either Oh, hey, Judy. You know, and either start into their questions or whatever they were looking to speak to my mother about. This case of mistaken identity became a running joke. You know, it was, ha ha, they thought that he was Judy. She didn't correct the collars. That's because she didn't mind being mistaken for Judy. It was just comforting to me because it felt natural.
你知道，要么“哦，嘿，朱迪”，你知道，要么直接开始问问题，或者他们想跟她妈妈谈的事情。这种身份错认成了一个经常开的玩笑。你知道，就是“哈哈，他们以为他是朱迪”。她没有纠正打电话的人。那是因为她不介意被误认为是朱迪。这对我来说只是感到安慰，因为它感觉很自然。
She was raised as a boy, but now decades later she identifies as a transgender woman. We're not using her legal name at her request because it's a man's name. She's experienced the deli became a template for the rest of her life. She listened to her voice and she listened to the way others heard her voice. There was always a gap between the two. She first tried to sound more masculine, to fit in with the way the world saw her. So I would consciously make an effort to try to talk a little deeper. It was, you know, I practiced it.
她小时候被当作男孩抚养，但现在几十年过去了，她认同自己是一位跨性别女性。应她的要求，我们没有使用她的法定姓名，因为那是一个男人的名字。她经历过的那家熟食店成了她余生的一块模板。她倾听自己的声音，也倾听别人听到她声音的方式。这两者之间总是存在着差距。她最初试图让声音听起来更具男性化，以融入这个世界看她的方式。因此，我会刻意努力让说话声音听起来低沉一点。就是，你知道的，我练习过。
And I woke up in the morning, I got myself up here. One way she practiced was to sing along with the doors, tool, and nine-inch nails. Attended to sort of go towards heavier music. You know, it's raspy, deep, yelling almost voices. I'm going wrong, oh night long. Sounding more masculine became second nature, but it wore on her. My entire life I have been playing the role of a boy. And it is exhausting.
我早上醒来，我从这里振作起来。她练习的一种方式是跟着The Doors、Tool和Nine Inch Nails乐队一起唱歌。倾向于偏向更重口味的音乐。你知道，那是沙哑的、低沉的、几乎是在吼叫的声音。我要错啦，噢，整整一个夜晚。听起来更具男性化成了第二天性，但这也让她感到疲惫。我的一生都在扮演一个男孩的角色。这真的很累人。
It truly is. Years and years pass like this. A divorce, a second wife, two kids, and a cancer scare later, she began to reconsider how she wanted to sound. Instead of trying to sound more masculine, she now started to try to sound more feminine. Even prior to accepting that I was trans, before I could put a label on what I was, I consciously made an effort to not sound as masculine, and that started in my early 30s. Once again she used music as a way to practice.
确实如此。就这样一年又一年过去。经历了一次离婚、第二任妻子、两个孩子以及一次癌症惊魂后，她开始重新考虑自己希望声音听起来是什么样的。她不再试图让声音听起来更具男性化，而是开始尝试让声音听起来更具女性化。甚至在接受自己是跨性别者之前，在我能够为自己贴上标签之前，我就已经有意识地努力不让自己听起来那么男性化，那大约是在我30岁出头的时候。她再次把音乐作为练习的一种方式。
I would always sing in the car alone and I would attempt Britney Spears. I think I did it again, I would sort of turn my head towards my driver's side window. Because it would reflect the sound back to me a little more loudly so that I could hear the pitch and tone of my voice. And I would try to make my voice sound at a higher pitch without it sounding like I was trying. What did you hear? Did you hear the voice that you wanted to hear? No, no, I've never, I don't know that I have ever actually been able to hear the same voice that I hear. Come from me.
我总是独自在车里唱歌，我会模仿布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。我想我“又做了一次”，我会把头转向驾驶座一侧的车窗。因为这样会把声音稍微大声地反射回我这里，这样我就能听到我声音的音高和音调。我会试着让我的声音听起来更高亢，同时又听不出来是在刻意勉强。你听到了什么？你听到你想听到的声音了吗？没有，没有，我从来没有，我不知道我是否真的能够听到从我身上发出来的、和我自己听到的一样的声音。
She has spent a lifetime being dissatisfied with the way she sounds. She viscerally knows something, the rest of us often forget. Our voices shape who we are. They shape how other people think of us. This week on Hidden Brain, we look at the relationship between our voices and our identities. Voices about who you are, our voice signals, things about our personality. Plus, how technology might help people with vocal impairments find voices that reflect who they are. Once you close your eyes and let your mind relax, it doesn't take long to escape to that beautiful beach.
她花了一生时间对自己的声音感到不满。她深刻地知道一件事——我们其余人经常忘记的事。我们的声音塑造了我们是谁。它们塑造了其他人对我们的看法。本周的《隐藏关于》节目中，我们探讨了声音与身份之间的关系。关于你是谁的声音，我们的声音会传递关于我们个性的一些信息。此外，技术如何帮助有语音障碍的人找到能够反映他们本色的人声。一旦你闭上眼睛，让心灵放松，用不了多久你就能逃离到那片美丽的海滩。
And the ethical quandaries that arise when we can create personalized, customized voices. This is huge, they can make us say anything, not really anything. Jackie Cork used to love the sound of her voice. She spent her 20s in San Francisco. And like many young people living in the big city, she enjoyed going out with her friends. She danced to electronic music at clubs and drank at bars. She was outgoing. And she was a flirt. I have to admit I've always enjoyed flirting and so I was quite the flirter. It was sort
当我们能够创造个性化、定制化的声音时，就会产生伦理困境。这太厉害了，它们能让我们说任何话，其实也不是任何话。杰基·科克过去常常喜欢她自己声音的声音。她的20多岁是在旧金山度过的。像许多生活在大都市的年轻人一样，她喜欢和朋友们一起出去玩。她在俱乐部里随着电子音乐跳舞，在酒吧里喝酒。她很外向。而且她很爱调情。我不得不承认，我一直很享受调情，所以我是一个相当擅长调情的人。这算是一种
of a fun activity to help pass the day when you're doing something mundane. For Jackie, flirting was also a demonstration of her confidence. It reinforces my own identity, how I felt about myself. Fun, I'm somebody that people are attracted to, not just physically or sexually, but a person who people like. Jackie liked to be liked. She liked being someone people wanted to be around. When she thinks about who she was back then, she refers to that person as voice one Jackie. Voice one Jackie was really fun-loving, always joking, pretty carefree. For years, Jackie had been doing backpacking trips with her then boyfriend. All of our gear on our back, 50 pounds, 60 pounds, etc.
有趣的活动，可以在你做一些平凡的事情时帮助打发时间。对杰基来说，这也是她自信的一种表现。它巩固了我自己的身份，巩固了我对自己的感觉。有趣，我是那种吸引别人的人，不仅仅是身体上或性吸引力上，而是一个受人喜爱的人。杰基喜欢被人喜欢。她喜欢成为别人想要陪伴的人。当她回想当时的自己时，她把那个人称为“声音一号杰基”。声音一号杰基非常热爱生活、总是开玩笑、相当无忧无虑。多年来，杰基一直和当时的男友一起进行背包旅行。我们背上所有的装备，50磅、60磅等等。
Even carrying bottles of wine, you know, in the backpack. She'd been doing these backpacking trips for several years. But during a trip to a national forest in California, Jackie came up short. I couldn't go at one step further. I, you know, in being young, you think, you know, what could it be? There's nothing wrong with me in 20, whatever, 20, something years old. And I noticed, you can be really short of breath. And it was a real struggle. I finally made it, of course, but it was really slow and a real struggle to make it back.
甚至在背包里装着几瓶葡萄酒，你知道的。她进行这样的背包旅行已经好几年了。但在去加利福尼亚州的一个国家公园旅行时，杰基遇到了力不从心的情况。我一步也走不动了。你知道的，年轻的时候，你会想，你知道，这会是什么呢？我才20多岁，不管多少岁，我身上没有什么毛病。我注意到，你会感到非常气短。这真的是一场挣扎。我当然最终还是走到了，但走得很慢，而且历经艰难才走回来。
Hiking became too taxing for her. It finally made it, of course, but it was really slow and a real struggle to make it back. Hiking became too taxing for her, so she cut back and switched to ballet. But one day, during a series of relives, a more aerobically challenging dance move, Jackie felt light-headed and dizzy. It was serious. I had a seizure and all of the medical follow-up led me to discover that I had a lung disease. She was diagnosed with idiopathic pulmonary hypertension. It's a rare progressive disease where the blood vessels in the lung shrink and oxygen is not distributed properly.
徒步旅行对她来说变得太吃力了。当然，她最终还是走回去了，但速度非常慢，而且历经艰难才返回。徒步旅行对她来说变得太吃力了，所以她减少了徒步，转而练习芭蕾舞。但是有一天，在一系列更为考验有氧耐力的芭蕾舞动作——弹跳（relevés）中，杰基感到头重脚轻、头晕目眩。情况很严重。我癫痫发作了，所有的后续医疗检查让我发现我患有一种肺病。她被诊断出患有特发性肺动脉高压。这是一种罕见的进行性疾病，肺部的血管收缩，氧气无法正常输送。
There's no cure for it except for lung transplant. In 2008 at 32, Jackie received a double lung transplant. The surgery was successful. Within weeks, she was out of the hospital and back in the Down studio. In 2010, she left San Francisco to explore Latin America and Europe. In 2010, she left San Francisco to explore Latin America and Europe. But her body began to reject her new lungs. Before long, Jackie was back in the hospital, this time in Switzerland, waiting for another lung transplant. I had the surgery in January of 2013, and I was asleep still for a done or month and a half.
除了肺移植外，这种病无药可救。2008年，32岁的杰基接受了双肺移植手术。手术很成功。几周内，她就出院并回到了舞蹈工作室。2010年，她离开旧金山去探索拉丁美洲和欧洲。2010年，她离开旧金山去探索拉丁美洲和欧洲。但她的身体开始排异新的肺部。没过多久，杰基又回到了医院，这次是在瑞士，等待另一次肺移植。我在2013年1月做了手术，并且昏迷了一个半月左右。
When she woke up, she found her surgery had been successful, except for one very important thing. I couldn't speak. I couldn't speak. During the operation, the medical staff had used a ventilator to help her breathe. So I was intubated. That means they basically have a tube
当她醒来时，她发现手术很成功，除了一个非常重要的事情。我不会说话了。我不会说话了。在手术过程中，医护人员使用呼吸机来帮助她呼吸。所以我插管了。这意味着他们基本上有一根管子
that they put inside your mouth and it goes down your throat and they send that down into your lungs. And during this intubation, the tube was rigid enough to cause some damage to my vocal cords. Jackie began speech therapy and within a few weeks she slowly regained the ability to speak. But the voice that came out of her mouth? It wasn't her voice. My voice changed, it's raspy, or it's broken a bit. Ever since, speaking has been hard work. Yeah, I really have to push my vocal. I feel it. It's actually a physical effort. Like I'm actually squeezing the vocal cords. As hard as I can to make
放进你的嘴里，它一直延伸到你的喉咙，然后他们把管子送进你的肺里。在这次插管过程中，管子足够硬，对我的声带造成了一些损伤。杰基开始接受言语治疗，几周内她慢慢恢复了说话的能力。但是从她嘴里发出的声音呢？那不是她的声音。我的声音变了，变得沙哑，或者有点破碎。从那以后，说话成了一件苦差事。是的，我真的得用力发出声音。我能感觉到。这实际上是一个体力活。就像我真的在挤压声带。拼尽全力去发出
the loudest sound possible to get to be to be heard and it's very tiring. The harder it became to produce sound, the more self-conscious she became about the way she sounded. I feel less confident. I'm aware of how people might perceive me. So I'm a little more shy. I don't approach people like I used to. Jackie believes the change in her voice has led to a dramatic change in her personality. For much of her life, her voice was a manifestation of her confidence. I used to go to clubs quite a bit, you know, but you know, when you have a normal voice, you can still talk to people in those environments where it's kind of loud and noisy, or bars to meet friends or to flirt,
最大的声音，以便被人听到，这非常累人。声音越难发出，她就越对自己的声音感到不自在。我感觉不那么自信了。我很在意别人可能会如何看待我。所以我变得更害羞了一点。我不再像以前那样主动接近别人了。杰基相信，她声音的改变导致了她性格的戏剧性转变。在她的大部分人生中，她的声音是她自信的体现。我过去经常去俱乐部，你知道的，但你知道，当你拥有正常的声音时，你仍然可以在那种嘈杂的环境中与人交谈，比如在酒吧里结交朋友或者调情，
like I like doing. But, you know, those places now, I don't really go to anymore. Jackie, a woman who once described herself as carefree and outgoing, who took pride in her ability to flirt, became withdrawn, reserved. You know, I have tons of scars all over my body, and that plays on my confidence as well. But in public life, people can't see those scars, and I feel like my voice is that, that, you know, that scar they can hear, you know? They know something's wrong. And they know, oh, maybe she's weak, maybe she's sick. Just by hearing my voice, it's the signal. Our voices communicate so much more than mere information.
就像我喜欢做的那样。但是，你知道，那些地方我现在真的不怎么去了。杰基，这个曾经形容自己无忧无虑、性格外向、并为自己调情能力感到骄傲的女人，变得内向、矜持。你知道，我全身都有大量的伤疤，这也会影响我的自信。但在公众生活中，人们看不到那些伤疤，我觉得我的声音就是那个，那个，你知道的，他们能听到的伤疤，你知道吗？他们知道出了问题。他们知道，哦，也许她很虚弱，也许她生病了。仅凭听到我的声音，这就是一个信号。我们的声音所传达的信息远远不止单纯的信息。
They communicate our feelings, our temperament, our identity. When we come back, how scientists are weaving this insight into custom-built voices. I can't wait for my friends to hear my new voice. Scientists have been trying for more than two centuries to analyze the human voice, decode its components, and recreate it. An early success came from a man named Homer Dudley. He developed an organ-like machine that he called the voter. It worked using special keys and a foot pedal, and was capable of creating about 20 different
它们传达我们的感情、我们的气质、我们的身份。当我们回来时，科学家将如何把这种洞察力融入定制的声音中。我等不及让我的朋友们听到我的新声音了。两个多世纪以来，科学家们一直试图分析人类的声音、解码其组成部分并将其重现。早期的成功来自一个名叫霍默·达德利（Homer Dudley）的人。他开发了一种类似风琴的机器，称之为“Voder”（电子声码器）。它通过特殊的琴键和脚踏板来运作，能够制造大约20种不同的
electronic buzzes and sounds. When those sounds were combined, they formed words. The voter fascinated people at the 1939 World's Fair in New York. Well, we've heard the voter make a word, and by combining words, of course, we get a sentence. For example, Helen, but you have the voters say, cheese saw me? Cheese. Uh... Cheese. That sounded awfully flat. How about a little expression?
电子蜂鸣声和声音。当这些声音组合在一起时，就形成了单词。Voder在1939年纽约世界博览会上深深吸引了人们。好的，我们已经听到Voder发出了一个单词，当然，通过组合单词，我们就能得到一个句子。例如，海伦，但你让Voder说，“cheese saw me”（奶酪看见了我）？Cheese。呃……Cheese。听起来未免太死板了。加点感情怎么样？
Say the sentence in answer to these questions. Who saw you? Cheese. Uh... whom did she say? Cheese. Uh... Well did she see you or hear you?
用这个句子回答以下问题。谁看见你了？Cheese。呃……她说是谁？Cheese。呃……她是看见你还是听见你？
Cheese. Oh! The voter was an early example of electronic speech, but it was cumbersome to operate and required special training. Over the next 40 years, speech scientists continued studying the components of the human voice. The eventually developed methods to mathematically map the acoustic patterns and phonetic properties of natural speech, vowels, syllable constructions, consonants. to be or not to be. That is a question. I can read stories that speak never loud. I do not understand what the work means when I read them.
Cheese。哦！Voder是电子语音的早期例子，但它操作笨重，需要专门的训练。在接下来的40年里，语音科学家继续研究人类语音的组成部分。他们最终开发出了一些方法，可以从数学上绘制出自然语音的声学模式和语音属性，比如元音、音节结构、辅音。生存还是毁灭。这是一个问题。我可以大声朗读故事。当我阅读时，我不明白这些作品的意思。
This is a complete record track making. You are listening to the right of a machine. Well, we know our A B key. By the 80s, Speed Synthesis was no longer the staff of science demonstrations at shows and fairs. Text to speech systems are beginning to be applied in many ways, including aid for the handicapped, medical aid, and teaching devices. The first kind of aid to be considered as a talking aid for the locally handicapped. The research of Dennis Clatt at MIT paved the way for the voices we might be familiar with today, many of them used in assistive communication devices. I am beautiful Betty, the standard female voice. I am view of cherry, a very large person with the teeth voice.
这是一个完整的录音轨道制作。你正在收听一台机器的发言。好吧，我们知道我们的A B键。到20世纪80年代，语音合成不再只是展会和集市上的科学演示工具。文本转语音系统开始在许多方面得到应用，包括残疾人援助、医疗援助和教学设备。第一类被考虑的援助是针对地方残疾人的会话辅助工具。麻省理工学院（MIT）的丹尼斯·克拉特（Dennis Klatt）的研究，为我们今天可能熟悉的声音铺平了道路，其中许多声音被用于辅助通信设备。我是美丽的贝蒂，标准女性声音。我是樱桃景观，一个声音很有特色的身材魁梧的人。
I am the standard male voice, perfect all. This last one by the way, became famous after Stephen Hawking adopted it. Speech technology has come a long way in the year since Homeradugly unveiled the voter. But in many ways, synthetic voices still sounded synthetic. They didn't convey all the information that's packed into the human voice. Voice is identity, right? Voice is about who you are, our voice signals, how old we are. Our voice signals, our gender, our voice signals, you know, things about our personality. Rupert Patel is a speech scientist at Northeastern University. Perhaps more than many people, she has thought a lot about the human voice.
我是标准男性声音，完美的保罗。顺便说一句，这最后一种声音在斯蒂芬·霍金采用它之后变得非常有名。自从霍默·达德利推出Voder以来，语音技术已经取得了长足的进步。但在很多方面，合成声音听起来仍然很合成。它们没有传达出融入人类声音中的所有信息。声音就是身份，对吧？声音关乎你是谁，我们的声音会发出信号，表明我们的年龄。我们的声音会发出信号，表明我们的性别，我们的声音会发出信号，你知道的，还有我们的个性。鲁帕尔·帕特尔是东北大学的一名语音科学家。或许比许多人更甚，她对人类的声音有过深入的思考。
When she misses her mother, for instance, Rupert has a special technique to evoke her presence. That's right. My parents now live in LA and I live here in Boston. And oftentimes I find myself imitating my mom, you know, say, oh, beta, how are you today? You know, or something like that. I'll imitate her the way she might say something. I might say that the same way to my daughter or something like that. But what I'm evoking is my mother's voice, primarily, to feel the closeness of her here.
例如，当她想念母亲时，鲁帕尔有一种特殊的技巧来唤起母亲的存在。没错。我的父母现在住在洛杉矶，而我住在波士顿。我经常发现自己在模仿我妈，你知道的，比如，“哦，贝塔，你今天过得怎么样？”你知道的，或者诸如此类的话。我会模仿她可能会说某种话的方式。我可能会用同样的方式对我的女儿说这样的话，诸如此类。但我所唤起的是我母亲的声音，主要是为了在这里感受到与她的亲密感。
In 2002, Rupert took these ideas with her to Denmark, where she was scheduled to speak at a conference for researchers and patients. I was presenting some of my early work showing that individuals with very severe speech disorder still have the ability to make sound and those sounds have some communicative content in them, some information that could be used. After her presentation, she walked out to the Exhibit Hall, and that's where she noticed
2002年，鲁帕尔带着这些想法来到丹麦，她计划在那里的一次研究人员和患者会议上发言。我当时在展示我早期的一些工作，表明那些有严重言语障碍的个人仍然有能力发出声音，并且这些声音中包含一些交际内容，包含一些可以被利用的信息。在她演讲结束后，她走进了展厅，正是在那里她注意到了一
something. Lots of people were using devices that produced synthetic voices. What was odd was that many of the voices didn't seem to match the people using them. At that point, back in 2002, we had very limited synthetic voice options available. And so I heard a little girl or a young girl using a device to talk with an adult male voice and having a conversation with another person, a middle-aged man, who also was using the same voice. And so, they're using different devices, but their voices were identical. She had just presented on the idea that our individual voices carry something unique
件事。许多人在使用产生合成声音的设备。奇怪的是，许多声音似乎与使用它们的人并不匹配。当时，也就是2002年，我们可用的合成声音选项非常有限。所以我听到一个小女孩或年轻女孩在使用一个设备说话，发出的是成年男性的声音，并且正与另一个人交谈，那另一个人是一个中年男子，他也使用了完全相同的声音。所以，他们使用的是不同的设备，但他们的声音却是一模一样的。她刚刚做过关于我们的个人声音带有某种独一无二的东西的演讲
about us. So why was this not reflected in these synthetic voices? Why are we giving them the same black box to speak through? There's got to be something that we can do, that we can harness the quality of the voices that they have, and imprint those or use that to give them a prosthetic voice that somehow reflects who they are and not just the same voice for everyone.
关于我们。那为什么这些合成声音没有反映这一点呢？为什么我们要给他们提供同一个黑箱来让他们通过其说话呢？肯定有什么事情是我们能做的，我们可以利用他们声音的质量，并将这些特质印刻下来，或者用它们来赋予他们一个假声，这个假声在某种程度上能反映出他们是谁，而不仅仅是每个人都用同一个声音。
Could a synthetic voice capture the richness of natural human speech? Rupert launched a company to answer this question. It's called Vocal ID and it uses machine learning and other artificial intelligence technologies to create personalized voices. So what synthetic speech is, is taking recordings of anyone and then taking those recordings and building a model of the voice quality of the annunciation abilities, right? You aren't necessarily analyzing it from a top down saying, well, this person has a high pitched voice to this person, has a low pitched voice, you're taking the recordings as basically the raw ingredients to feed to a machine learning algorithm or set
合成声音能否捕捉到自然人类语音的丰富性？鲁帕尔创办了一家公司来回答这个问题。它名为“Vocal ID”，利用机器学习和其他人工智能技术来创造个性化的声音。那么什么是合成语音呢？就是获取任何人的录音，然后利用这些录音建立一个关于发音能力的语音质量模型，对吧？你不一定是从自上而下的角度去分析它，比如“嗯，这个人声音高亢，那个人声音低沉”，你基本上是将录音作为喂给机器学习算法或一组算法的原始素材。
of algorithms really. And those are learning the patterns of the clarity of the person's s. The, you know, how that sound is changed in the different phonetic environments. The voice quality, aspects of, all of these are learned by the machine. It's really re-emulating these are learned by the machine, it's really re-emulating the human voice by machine. In other words, the idea is to build a model of how a person sounds. To do so, you use a vast range of examples of that person's speech.
算法确实如此。这些算法会学习一个人“s”发音清晰度的模式。你知道的，这些声音在不同语音环境下的变化情况。声音质量、各方面的特征，这些都是由机器来学习的。这实际上是通过机器重新模拟人类的声音。换句话说，其理念是建立一个关于一个人听起来是怎样的模型。要做到这一点，你需要使用该人言语的大量示例。
Then you use the model to produce spoken language that incorporates all the idiosyncrasies and texture of that person's voice. One of Ruppels' early clients was a young girl, male flack. Mave was born with cerebral palsy, she is in a beautiful family where she's two other older sisters. Ruppels' goal was to give Maeve her own unique synthetic voice. One that could express not just her words, but her identity. The first step was to record her. A-A-A-A-A- you know, when she's in a classroom with several other kids who also have communication disabilities,
然后，你使用该模型来产生包含该人声音的所有特质和质感的口语。鲁帕尔早期的客户之一是一个小女孩，梅夫·弗拉克（Maeve Flack）。梅夫生来患有脑瘫，她生活在一个美好的家庭里，还有两个姐姐。鲁帕尔的目标是赋予梅夫她自己独特的合成声音。一个不仅能表达她的话语，还能表达她的身份的声音。第一步是录制她的声音。啊——啊——啊——啊——啊——你知道的，当她在与其他也有沟通障碍的孩子一起上课时，
when she makes that sound, you know what's Maeve speaking. So we harnessed those sounds of Maeve's to create her unique voice for her. Then Rupert turned to Maeve's older sisters, Erin and Megan, who volunteered to record their voices so they could be blended with Maeve's. A scream is my guilty pleasure. That man ran fast. Erin and Megan read hundreds of sentences and phrases and uploaded them to a website for Rupert. Like a painter mixing a palette, Ruperal took elements of Maeve's voice and
当她发出那个声音时，你就知道那是梅夫在说话。所以我们利用了梅夫的那些声音来为她创造她独特的声音。接着，鲁帕尔找到了梅夫的姐姐埃琳（Erin）和梅根（Megan），她们自愿录制自己的声音，以便能与梅夫的声音融合在一起。尖叫声是我的隐秘罪恶。那个男人跑得很快。埃琳和梅根朗读了数百个句子和短语，并将它们上传到鲁帕尔的一个网站上。就像画家调色一样，鲁帕尔提取了梅夫声音中的元素，
mixed them with those of our sisters and other vocal donors to create what she calls a bespoke voice. I can't wait for my friends to hear my new voice. My parents are really happy I'm not addicted to Fortnite. I want to meet Taylor Swift. So we're hearing, you know, Maeve at this age in terms of her sound as well as her siblings' recordings, being combined and being produced through this speech and this ascension. It's possible that Maeve may decide as she gets older that her voice needs to age with her. She'll need a new, bespoke voice at that point. The same technology can also be used to preserve a person's existing voice. Sometimes, this is done when a person faces the prospect of losing his voice.
并将它们与她的姐姐们以及其他声音捐赠者的声音混合在一起，创造出她所谓的定制声音。我迫不及待地想让我的朋友们听到我的新声音。我的父母真的很高兴我对《堡垒之夜》没有成瘾。我想见泰勒·斯威夫特。所以我们听到的是，你知道的，梅夫这个年龄的声音特征，以及她兄弟姐妹的录音，被结合在一起，并通过这种言语和这种发音产生出来。梅夫随着年龄的增长，可能会决定她的声音需要随着她一起变老。到那时，她将需要一个新的定制声音。同样的技术也可以用来保留一个人现有的声音。有时，这是在一个人面临失去声音的前景时做的。
These could be individuals who are losing their voice to degenerative conditions so slowly their voice is changing, such as ALS or Parkinson's disease, and then those who the trauma is actually far more pronounced for individuals with something like head and neck cancer where they learn that they're going to have their voice box removed within a couple of weeks. Lonnie Blanchard confronted this traumatic news in 2018. Doctors had diagnosed him with cancer and said surgery was the only option. Lonnie had to have his tongue removed. Here he is speaking to the BBC.
这些人可能是那些因退行性疾病而正在失去声音的人，因此他们的声音在慢慢改变，例如渐冻症（ALS）或帕金森病，然后还有那些创伤更为明显的人，比如头颈癌患者，他们得知自己的喉头将在几周内被切除。朗尼·布兰查德（Lonnie Blanchard）在2018年面临了这一痛苦的消息。医生诊断他患了癌症，并表示手术是唯一的选择。朗尼不得不切除舌头。这里是他在对BBC讲话。
Now that I know I'm going to lose my voice, I got to get some sayings down on a person recorder to get what I would normally say to my wife and kids. But every time I go to do that, I draw up a blank. By the time Lonnie started working with Rupal, he only had a few weeks to back his voice. We helped him get set up in terms of the microphone he would need and things like that. Rupal worked with Lonnie to build a database of sound samples before his surgery.
既然我知道我要失去声音了，我就得在个人录音机上录下一些日常用语，把我通常会对妻子和孩子说的话录下来。但每次我去做这件事时，我都大脑一片空白。当朗尼开始与鲁帕尔合作时，他只有几周的时间来备份他的声音。我们在他需要的麦克风等方面给予了他帮助，帮他完成了设置。鲁帕尔与朗尼合作，在手术前建立了一个声音样本数据库。
He recorded sentences that gave Ruperl and her colleagues the different kinds of sounds they would need to build a new voice. I wish we could get acquainted. I'm going to be a teacher when I grow up. After Lonnie banged his voice, Ruperl used the recordings to create a personalized voice for him. The difference between his voice and Maeve's voice is that Rupal didn't need to blend voices from donors. Lonnie was his own donor.
他录制了各种句子，为鲁帕尔和她的同事们构建新声音所需的各种声音提供了素材。真希望我们能认识。我长大后要当一名老师。在朗尼备份了自己的声音后，鲁帕尔利用这些录音为他创造了一个个性化的声音。他的声音与梅夫的声音的不同之处在于，鲁帕尔不需要融合来自捐赠者的声音。朗尼自己就是捐赠者。
Those voice samples then are used, are cleaned up and annotated by machine actually, and then used to feed into the algorithms we have to create the synthetic voice. Similar to Maeve, Lonnie uses an assistive device, in his case an iPad. He can type out what he wants to say, and hear his voice speaking to his family. Once you close your eyes and let your mind relax, it doesn't take long to escape to their beautiful beach. mind relax. It doesn't take long to escape to the beautiful beach. It's really empowering. It's continued to be a way that he can connect to family members and feel part that part of him is not fully lost. While most of us will never have the experience of losing our voices and having to obtain synthetic voices as replacements, increasingly many of us are coming into contact with these voices.
然后，这些声音样本会被机器清理并加上注释，接着被用来输入到我们的算法中，以创造出合成声音。与梅夫类似，朗尼使用的是辅助设备，在他这个案例中是一个iPad。他可以打出他想说的话，并听到他的声音向家人说话。一旦你闭上眼睛，让心灵放松，用不了多久你就能逃离到那片美丽的海滩。心灵放松。用不了多久你就能逃离到那美丽的海滩。这真的赋能于人。这仍然是他与家人联系的一种方式，让他觉得他的一部分并没有完全丢失。虽然我们大多数人永远不会经历失去声音并不得不获取合成声音来替代的体验，但越来越多的人正在接触到这些声音。
Hey Siri, how many ounces are in a cup? One cup is eight blue ounces. Hey Siri, set a timer. For how long? 56 minutes. OK, sure, 56 minutes. Starting now. Alexa, can you play music? Play some jazz.
嘿，Siri，一杯有多少盎司？一杯是八流体盎司。嘿，Siri，设置一个定时器。多长时间？56分钟。好的，没问题，56分钟。从现在开始。Alexa，你能放音乐吗？放点爵士乐。
There's a station you might like. Synthetic voices are already changing our lives. And it's likely we're going to become even more reliant on them. In May 2018, Google revealed a new program it was working on. CEO Sundar Pichai presented it to an audience of software developers. The technology is called Google Duplex. It allows you to make a restaurant reservation through a voice assistant. Hi, how many are you?
有一个你可能会喜欢的电台。合成声音已经在改变我们的生活。而且我们很可能会更加依赖它们。2018年5月，谷歌透露了它正在研发的一个新项目。首席执行官桑达尔·皮查伊向软件开发人员观众展示了它。这项技术被称为“谷歌双工（Google Duplex）”。它允许你通过语音助手预订餐厅。嗨，你们一共几个人？
Hi, I'd like to reserve a table for Wednesday's e7. For 7 people? It's for 4 people. 4 people, when? 9? 9, Wednesday at 6 p.m. Oh, actually we live here for like, up to like, five people.
嗨，我想为周三晚上7点预订一张桌子。7个人？是4个人。4个人，什么时候？9点？9点，周三下午6点。哦，实际上我们这里最多接待五个人。
For people you can come. How long is the wait usually to be seated? For when tomorrow or weekday or? For next Wednesday, the seven. Oh, no, it's not too busy. You can't go for people, okay? Oh, I got you. Thanks. Bye-bye.
你们四个人可以来。通常等位要等多久才能入座？明天的还是工作日的？下周三，7点。哦，不，不是太忙。你们四个人可以去，好的？哦，明白了。谢谢。再见。
The audience is laughing and applauding because the man making the call isn't a man, but a machine. It didn't seem like it was a robotic voice. The robotic voices were used to are the voices like when you are in a parking garage and you hear the, you know, please place your ticket with the stripe facing to the right. Very, very, uh, canned sort of speech. This was far more sophisticated and much more like you and I talk with hesitations and pauses and ums and us. You think it's a human on the other end. Now of course one of the
观众们在笑并鼓掌，因为打电话的那个人不是人，而是一台机器。它听起来不像是一个机器人声音。我们习惯的机器人声音就像你在停车场车库里听到的那种，你知道的，“请将有条纹的一面朝右插入您的票”。非常非常……那种生硬的语音。这要复杂得多，更像是你和我说话时那样，带有犹豫、停顿、“嗯”和“呃”。你会以为另一端是一个真人。现在当然，
things about that voice that Google had is that it did seem like a convincing voice but if you need to convince me that that voice is not just a human voice but a particular human's voice. You need to convince me that this is not just anyone calling for a restaurant reservation but it's Barack Obama calling for a restaurant reservation. Presumably Barack Obama calling for a restaurant reservation. Presumably now the bar is much, much higher. That's right, it is. Barack Obama though does have a ton of his audio on the internet.
谷歌那个声音的特点之一是，它确实听起来很有说服力，但如果你需要说服我那个声音不仅是一个人声，而且是一个特定的人的声音。你需要说服我，这不仅仅是随便什么人为餐厅预订打电话，而是贝拉克·奥巴马在为餐厅预订打电话。据推测，贝拉克·奥巴马在为餐厅预订打电话。据推测，现在门槛要高得多、高得多。没错，确实如此。不过，贝拉克·奥巴马在互联网上确实有大量的音频。
And there's a lot more audio to make, his voice than there is, my voice, for example. And so, yeah, but it's absolutely possible to learn. And if you have long enough, you can learn anybody's voice and if you have enough data. It's not hard to see how bad actors could misuse this. Create havoc in people's lives, trouble at companies, political misinformation.
而且有更多可用于合成他声音的音频，比如相比于我的声音。所以，是的，但学习是完全可能的。如果你有足够长的时间，如果你有足够的数据，你可以学会任何人的声音。不难看出坏人会如何滥用这一点。在人们的生活中制造混乱，给公司带来麻烦，制造政治虚假信息。
That's absolutely, I mean, we're seeing deep fakes in video. We've seen, you know, President Obama's face with being manipulated and the audio coming out, you know, people creating these fake media in video and you're also seeing an audio. That's exactly why the security aspects of what we're doing are trying to detect. Is that fake audio or is that real? Is part of that fake audio or is part of that real, right? So this isn't completely sci-fi. It isn't so far away. It isn't necessarily 20, you know, 2028.
那是绝对的，我的意思是，我们正在视频中看到深度伪造（deepfakes）。我们已经看到，你知道的，奥巴马总统的脸被操纵了，音频也随之出来了，你知道，人们在视频中制造这些虚假媒体，你也能在音频中看到。这正是我们正在做的安全方面的努力试图去检测的原因。那是假音频还是真音频？那是假音频的一部分还是真音频的一部分，对吧？所以这并不完全是科幻小说。它没有那么遥远。它不一定是20，你知道，2028年。
It's probably 2020. So we've got to get our defenses up in terms of questioning where the authenticity of audio just says we do video. In 2017, a Canadian company called Liobird showed how audio deepfakes might work in politics. This is huge. They can make us say anything now really anything. The good news is that they will offer the technology to anyone. This is huge. How does their technology work?
它可能是2020年。所以我们必须建立起我们的防线，就像我们对待视频一样，去质疑音频的真实性。2017年，一家名为Lyrebird的加拿大公司展示了音频深度伪造如何在政治中起作用。这太厉害了。他们现在可以让我们说任何话，真的任何话。好消息是，他们会将这项技术提供给任何人。这太厉害了。他们的技术是如何运作的？
Hey guys, I think that they used deep learning and artificial neural networks. By 2019, deep fake audio technology had gotten even better. Shortly after critics pan the final season of Game of Thrones, a YouTube channel called Eating Things with Famous People put out this tongue-in-cheek video showing the supposed remorse of the lead character, John Snow. Spoofing a TV show is one thing, but imagine such high quality deepfakes occurring in a more high-stake setting. Voices are increasingly being used by financial institutions to authenticate
大家好，我想他们使用的是深度学习和人工神经网络。到2019年，深度伪造音频技术变得更加出色。在评论家对《权力的游戏》最终季给出差评后不久，一个名为“和名人一起吃东西（Eating Things with Famous People）”的YouTube频道发布了这个带有讽刺意味的视频，展示了主角琼恩·斯诺所谓的懊悔。恶搞一个电视节目是一回事，但想象一下，在风险更高的环境中发生这种高质量的深度伪造。声音正越来越多地被金融机构用来验证
the identities of consumers. Recently, Rupert worked with a bank to assess how vulnerable it was to vocal hacking. We tested their authentication system by creating synthetic samples or synthetic voices of particular individuals who are enrolled in their authentication system and we try to test those voices against the system to see if we could get through with the synthetic voices. And we were not able to do that for every single voice, but we were able to do it for some
消费者的身份。最近，鲁帕尔与一家银行合作，评估其对语音黑客攻击的脆弱性。我们通过为在其身份验证系统中注册的特定个人创建合成样本或合成声音，来测试他们的身份验证系统，并试图用这些合成声音来测试该系统，看我们是否能用合成声音蒙混过关。我们没能对每一个声音都做到这一点，但我们确实对其中一些声音成功了
voices. And so it just starts to show that there is a vulnerability in this technology. So how would you guard against it? Well there are many ways to guard against it. One is you can classify the difference between, is the audio signal I'm listening to, is it synthetic or is it human? As the synthetic voices become better and better sounding, that will be a more difficult decision to make. And it is something that if we can proactively solve,
声音。所以这刚开始表明这项技术存在脆弱性。那么你将如何防范它呢？嗯，有很多方法可以防范。其中之一是你可以区分差异，我正在听的音频信号，它是合成的还是人类的？随着合成声音听起来越来越好，这将是一个更难做出的决定。这也是一件事，如果我们能够主动解决，
I think, or at least start to address, we're going to be way ahead of the curve than if we're trying to clean up our mess after the fact. Despite the potential risks of these new technologies, Ruperl is also optimistic. Voice synthesis tools have the potential risks of these new technologies, Ruperl is also optimistic. Voice synthesis tools have the potential to allow people to craft the voice they hear on the outside so that it matches the identity they feel on the inside. Ideally in the future, these decisions are made by the end user themselves.
我认为，或者至少开始着手解决，我们将远远领先于事后才去收拾烂摊子的情况。尽管这些新技术存在潜在风险，但鲁帕尔同样持乐观态度。语音合成工具具有这样的潜在风险，鲁帕尔同样持乐观态度。语音合成工具具有这样的潜力，可以让人们打造他们在外面听到的声音，使其与他们在内心感受到的身份相匹配。理想情况下，在未来，这些决定将由最终用户自己做出。
Like, oh, I actually want that to be sound a little breathier. I'd love that to sound a little bit more confident. And I mean, how does that translate to the acoustics? We don't quite know yet, but that's actually, I think, where when we can finally give the control of what the voice sounds like to the individual, I mean, that's the holy grail. Uh... She's a... A... Hello, I am T. T. T.
比如，“哦，我其实希望那个声音听起来稍微带点气声。”“我希望那个声音听起来更自信一点。”我的意思是，这如何转化为声学效果？我们还不太清楚，但实际上，我认为，当我们可以最终把声音听起来是怎样的控制权交回给个人时，我的意思是，这就是圣杯。呃……她是一个……一个……你好，我是T. T. T.
Why are you reading machine? You are listening to the rights of a talking aid for the locally handicapped. I am beautiful Betty, the standard female voice. I am the standard male voice, perfect Paul. I was sad because there was no ice cream in the freezer. Asking as clear and the stars are sprinkling. I can't wait for my friends to hear my voice. One cup is eight flu bounces. You are listening to a machine.
你为什么要阅读机器？你正在收听的是地方残疾人会话辅助工具的发音。我是美丽的贝蒂，标准女性声音。我是标准男性声音，完美的保罗。我很难过，因为冰箱里没有冰激凌。要求像晴空和星星在闪烁一样清晰。我等不及让我的朋友们听到我的声音了。一杯是八流体盎司。你正在收听一台机器。
This is huge. How does their technology work? Hey guys, I think that they used deep learning in our official neural networks. Hi, I'd like to introduce a table for Wednesday V7. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Parthascha, Jenny Schmidt and Laura Quarell. Special thanks to Brent Bachman, Greg Sauer and Kébon Jones.
这太厉害了。他们的技术是如何运作的？大家好，我想他们使用的是深度学习和人工神经网络。嗨，我想为周三V7预订一张桌子。本周的节目由托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）剪辑。我们的团队包括帕尔塔·沙（Parthascha）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）。特别感谢布伦特·巴赫曼（Brent Bachman）、格雷格·绍尔（Greg Sauer）和凯博·琼斯（Kébon Jones）。
Our aunts and hero this week is Rebecca Raul. She's part of NPR's team looking at our changing interactions with smart speakers. She helped us record some of the smart devices you heard in this week's episode. Thanks Rebecca. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend. We're always looking for new people to discover hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们本周的幕后英雄是丽贝卡·劳尔（Rebecca Raul）。她是NPR团队的一员，负责研究我们与智能音箱不断变化的互动。她帮助我们录制了你在本周节目中听到的一些智能设备的声音。谢谢你，丽贝卡。如果你喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。我们一直在寻找新的人来发现“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。